foreign
[Music]
did things happening to your family
you're happiness for a reason
hello listen to me who is this
[Music]
guy on the phone
did he have an accent what kind Guyanese
Guyanese
[Music]
um
does that mean something to you
you do exactly what I've instructed you
to do
be restored what you think up is next
they're gonna kill that bite
but we're gonna see them life is a
series a little loyalty tests you have
to make a choice who to follow and who
to trust
it makes no sense that we would be
targeted you okay there's something else
going on they're all hiding
whatever
cause
it's worth it
what is it with your family and secrets
you're fishing
we know exactly how to survive this game
[Music]
what he did was not okay and we're in
this mess now I'm here because of it
Nobody Knows the big picture
but you will
I promise
[Music]
thank you